welcome back to the red chives and show
notches to our viewers and listeners but
to of to our next guest who you can
catch at the Addison Improv in Dallas
Texas on September 25th and zany's
Zanies everybody in Chicago Illinois on
October 10th and then a week later in
Las Vegas Nevada at the Alliant a casino
in Orleans showroom Frank Caliendo good
to see you sir you know it's great to be
back with you rich
told you the whole show is gonna be I've
been listening to that high voice I'm
working on my low voice for dramatic
roles yes I've been watching people on
your television program that gives you
various forms but various platforms on
the Internet just listening to you and
I've seen people with much better
careers than me yes and they come in
with a calm presence okay instead of
this stupid high-energy thing I've
always done just to entertain you and
sometimes annoy the audience so I've
decided that today yes
I'm going to do this as long as I can
because she stopped me well so we won't
have Lou Holtz doing Game of Thrones no
I will not pander I will not pander to
you or the audience looking for
impersonations various sports here's
another thing Richard that I yes French
is real yes my name is just Frank okay
you can call me that okay you don't mean
it
nothing's making sense today but it
doesn't have to know you've come in with
a plan on the Richard Yzerman show right
this is anything I did not realize in
all this time I've been on the show
watched the show in its years yeah over
the years you don't always just talk
sports no and how I miss that is idiotic
I think made me realize that my powers
of perception are lacking like in like
in Craig it there's spider-sense
I'm the fly sense like just going around
and black and so you couldn't you
couldn't
that when when you're just riffing off
on Adam Schefter saying polysyllabic
vegetable my sources you're doing it
again
what you're doing is playing a game
where you're leading me into various
impressions that you want to hear I was
trying to stay away this do a high
concept comedy piece and what I am doing
instead is once again pandering to your
whims and making sure everything that
you wanted to get out of the segment yes
becomes part of it and makes us all
happy except for the one sad clown
sitting in a chair
all dark clothing to appear thinner yes
then he's ever appeared on camera before
you look like put stuff in my hair I uh
I got I got the product I got I did that
myself two before I got on the plane I
put the stuff in the hair I don't know
what it is this is like like other times
you've come on sometimes you just do
step off the plane like you you you just
did yeah and you don't have makeup on
and your hair is all messy that's like
the coming out of Delaware Joe Flacco
now what I'm seeing this is the elite
quarterback Joe Flacco look I'm saying
this is the dumbest six for backing yes
this is I like the shoes your shoes my
son my son
these are Easy's I don't have a
sponsorship yet impressive my son's get
like he's trying to dress me better and
help me yeah I'm learning a lot from my
kids about how to not embarrass them as
much hey I don't know if I told you this
before I let my son run my Instagram
account I've actually started doing my
own Instagram account okay so I let my
son run it and he said he's very good
he's responsible kid yes but he said can
I follow my friends and they're like
absolutely not realizing he is a 15 year
old boy a female friends yeah
and then there were stuff that I'm like
American Beauty I'm going to jail like
there's there I'm looking at things I'm
like we gotta not no more get rid of
this stuff hold on deep voice back so so
what if what is left out at you that
made you think hey this is more than
just a sports show that I've been on no
I just stories I saw Bill Hader a couple
weeks talking about the Schwarzenegger
thing right that was that was awesome
and I just he's one of those guys that I
look at and go gosh what a great career
yeah that wasn't that was Dan Patrick
show but that's what was it really yeah
yeah oh but it's okay it's a six-hour
block here folds up and folds is what I
was actually thinking dan is a great
show against him can't believe this
studio and he left us with a nice carpet
it's true that's what I have this carpet
in the house I don't use I I'm sorry I
did make that mistake that was good I
wasn't trying to but now I'm going to
milk it and talk about all of his guests
that I loved he's gonna love this you
know fritzy sitting there going this is
awesome the worst emailer in the world I
know we shouldn't be doing this is
terrible I always want to talk about
this an issue but his his emails make
you feel this is a person who his Jays a
great guy I know he's a terrible emailer
he's a worst texter looking forward to
being on the show he'll be like whatever
does like sounds great you don't believe
it his reply you're like why are you
mocking me as though you're talking
about the wrong guests on the Rich Eisen
shows ha
carpeting rug so Ben Folds is one that I
did see YES on here and it's really
great to be on my final appearance in my
chosen show
[Music]
radio stations number of times where I
have Dan has been somebody came up to
him they they think I'm him and he's me
no really happens I never get that I
know I don't want to tell you why but I
would never know so Ben Folds is talking
about William Shatner yes and I have a
fun Shatner story oh yes
friend of mine John Homburg and I've
been doing a podcast it's just breaking
all sorts of records not with listeners
or anything oh and Frank no no this is
this with John Homburg this is more like
us okay we're just trying to take over
for you is what I'm trying here okay
trying to get Bill Hader on elite guest
turn the page it's okay and I'm stuck no
so but we've been doing it we started
doing this you made me lose my place
William Shatner Shatner look at that
picture on the screen okay he's trying
he's big number one radio guy in in
Phoenix yes and so he got this
opportunity to host a panel with William
Shatner's like you got to come and meet
him in the green room and we did so I
went out there and Shatner used to watch
me doing like the picks on Fox and stuff
like that okay the funny thing is I
guess he used to watch them with Tom
Batali and Valerie Bertinelli who
happened to live next door do you know
who that you know who they are
Valerie Bertinelli is like one day at a
time right yeah she's got a cooking show
like super nice people hugged her at a
changing hands bookstore and then we
became friends I wish that weren't true
but it's 100% real
so I tell Shatner I was I was in your
backyard looking at your houses like wha
how could that be like well I'm friends
with Val and Tom he's like okay that
suddenly make sense something Tom told
me to ask you about a golf cart and this
is this as a test man how great of an
actor Shatner is yeah he told a whole
story with it just one word
I go what happened with this golf cart
egos unbelievable
anyway wait a second you're on the golf
cart you turned it sideways we're doing
a wheelie
we ended up jumping a dog and then
landed in a creek and somehow had
somebody miss reprint ounce Creek is
Creek yes it was great my life so I was
like wow that's great
so he was just that it was the most cuz
you don't expect him to be just so calm
and subdued like I'm trying to be on
this episode today but he was fantastic
I got listen I have themes I've got
recurrent that's what people doing fo
drama do yes they have recurring themes
in their segments Frank Caliendo here on
the Rich Eisen show did you hear the
news that Shawshank Redemption was being
re-released I did not hear that Sonny
why in the world would they be doing
that good cuz it's so good what are they
releasing it on basic cable cuz it's
never been played there before right
it's kind of like it's a wonderful life
where you watch one part and for watch
them like a Tarantino film you watch the
middle see what happened at the end and
then go back to the beginning to put it
all together
is it the 25th anniversary yeah
September 23rd next week is the 25th
anniversary of the release Wow
one word unbelievable so my there's
another thing I think we have time
because like the Frank Caliendo we have
nothing but it so my daughter had broken
her elbow a year ago on her birthday
okay sorry to hear that yeah and she was
actually excited this is gonna sound
weird at first she was excited when
Roethlisberger broke his elbow this
weekend well I know it sounds bad but
it's I think it's the same thing okay
because she hasn't been able to
quarterback for a year she was replaced
by somebody named Mason and your family
is very
it's very us and every time I hear Mason
Rudolph I think Maya Rudolph like every
time somebody says Mason Rudolph I
picture Maya Rudolph doing Oprah going
hey you know that guy with that wouldn't
that be odd if out in San Francisco next
week out trots Maya Rudolph I think that
would be awesome
the Lonely Island shows up to I don't
know good I think that would be pretty
cool how would how I'm gonna go there
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it
how would Maddon call that you know yeah
this is this is a substitution we didn't
see coming
I mean I've seen a lot a lot of
substitutions in my day and this is one
but if you don't think you're gonna get
rid of Benoit but you know look at ben
roethlisberger closely he I think he he
just might be wreck-it ralph everything
every time I see my fans burger I'm like
I'm on a record that's right just
kidding that's a giant hands just God
just break everything up man so Ferrell
so yeah so that's why see did we do
enough of that when you get some
entertaining moments out of me so my
daughter had broken her elbow yes and
while it wasn't healing properly but in
the next year it still wasn't broken and
we went to this place called ace Comic
Con all right and it's ace con I've
gotten to be friends with them and
pretty cool we've gotten to meet some
different the first one I went to was in
Phoenix and we met Tom Hiddleston the
guy who plays Loki sure I'm Loki of
Asgard and a burdened with glorious
purpose you know what can you eat next
time I'm here can we get a full audience
can we bus an audience and I can hang
out JB because he was in spider-man with
another guy with a better career he was
in spider-man with Tom Holland which is
my daughter's gonna go meet him no can
this next comic-con
yeah and any time I can like say I'm
friends with some
knows him shootings on the cool so we go
to do we have the time I worry about
your commercials I want you to frankly I
know you're just a giver yeah that's
what it's about so we go to meet Josh
Brolin and Josh bro I had this video of
judgment I gave Adan booyah super
producer here's at the Rich Eisen
Network promise uh extravaganza Empire
was the word I was looking for REE Rich
Eisen Empire I like a can it put it
somewhere ship it out write it down
market before LeBron does oh just got to
get the Josh bro I have video of him
talking about using me as inspiration
for the movie w when he played Jordan to
play George W Bush in the movie w and he
does call me in the video calls me Frank
Caliendo
okay which is a reason I'm changing my
name right so I go and we go into this
line because I know the people at Ace
and I don't nobody tells him I'm coming
and I go to shake his hand he gives me
this look like it was almost a groom
face like what the heck's going on here
man like that kind of a thing yeah and
he I go hey Frank Caliendo and he just
looks at like Vic like an egg empty look
on his face like what's happening here
and then we go to we end up meeting him
later and Chris Evans is there who's a
huge Patriots fan I know we've had him
on this show course you did isn't yeah
we're not gonna say since not nobody
would give you a rug picture of your
daughter Amy Renner and there's Cheadle
yeah that's her Avengers themed birthday
party Zoe Saldana yeah they did not get
dressed up for it but it's believable so
so I'm talking to broli
as I call Josh Brolin when he's not
around and I'm like I'm just talking but
I got this video he's like you don't
understand you you were such an
inspiration for that movie Oliver and I
Oliver Stone not the kid from the
musical so he's like you you don't
understand how important
word that rule and Chris Nelms goes wait
a second what role are you talking about
and I do a decent Chris Evans yeah yeah
mostly the look and and he and bro and
Brolin before he can say anything I go
Thanos and Evans goes wait a second who
are you
I go Frank Allen he goes oh my god he
goes the Matt he starts get like like
it's awesome like it's incredible and my
daughter's going
Captain America knows my dad and we're
just having a conversation like we're
two Avengers about to say like I'm gonna
talk him out of this boiler alert I'm
gonna talk him into staying in the
current timeline at the end so and I'm
say I'm just sayin stupid stupid stuff
is coming out of my mouth just things
like you don't know what it's you it's
so awesome what an incredible career you
could be on the Rich Eisen show that's
and I could try and emulate you and show
you what an amazing crew you don't
understand what it's like to be
pigeonholed as one character Captain
America and I've seen some of the other
stuff he does I actually loved him the
Fantastic Four when it was done he's
incredible but it was so funny the stuff
I was trying to talk about but he was he
kept hitting me he's like that's funny
he's like that's good stuff like words
fan and I'm like you got the Super
Soldier Serum relax he's like you have
no idea he's like so he's just smacking
me around and we get done and my
daughter's like that was unbelievable
furs had to go and and they had to move
everything on but Chris Evans comes out
and takes another break and he's texting
somebody else he sees me he comes over
to talk to me a little bit more and
after we talked a little bit and I took
the time as like I'm busy Christopher
but Rich Eisen would want me to talk to
you right now so so we end up talking to
a little bit my daughter ends up going
that that was unbelievable and she goes
this is the best day of my life and I'm
like well mark it down because it's only
going downhill from here because there's
no way I can top that and I go why was
it so great she goes because you know
him
he liked you in the second time he
didn't have to talk to you no he wanted
to and I was like that that's so true
that points courtesy is it was a big
deal for us did you do your Belichick
impersonation
he was you know what
was calling things out he was like I was
yeah he was no he wasn't no no I was
just making fun of you and it didn't
Robert Downey jr. for him I was doing
little Robert Downey jr. and I was doing
it like this like no do it like I am
doing it it's not that good Dallas Texas
Chicago Illinois Las Vegas Nevada in
November the Potawatomi Hotel and Casino
in Milwaukee Wisconsin you're going
right there in the middle of Iowa larch
wood Iowa on December 12th Frank
Caliendo dot-com tickets are available
right there Frank Caliendo on Twitter
and now Instagram which he's running
himself to make sure he's an upstanding
citizen do you have a second we go into
commercial sounds like we are yeah yeah
okay I put my six eleven my friends six
eleven kid on there yesterday
guess who's like unblock of that on the
Instagram at Frank Kelly I know in there
and next time I'm on yes sir I'll be
going a little crazy and I'm gonna break
out the Gerry Alex Jones impression
which is the chemtrails changing how the
NFL is being developed fantastic Frank
Caliendo is here on the Rich Eisen show
anytime sir you know I'll be here for
the next day anytime except for the next
segment for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app